hello and welcome to the section on
non-quadratic
regularizers
so remember the idea of regularization
we want to choose a theta which both
minimizes the
empirical risk and also
makes the predictor be not too sensitive
so if i've got an x near an x tilde
then we'd like g theta of x to also be
close to g theta of x tilde
and the reason for this reduction in
sensitivity that we're going to put in
there
is that if you make the predictor too
sensitive then what happens is you end
up with something that doesn't
generalize well
and so this is a way of
forcing the predictor to be insensitive
to the data
and that makes the predictor generalized
better it's a way of preventing over
fitting and so what we do in order to
achieve this is we
use a regularizer a function r which is
a function of the parameters theta
and it's a real valued function of r
which measures the sensitivity of g
theta so that in particular when theta
is large then our function our
regularizer function is also large and
so by making the regularizer small
we'll make theta small and thereby will
make the sensitivity of g
theta small there's another way to think
about this and this is
very common in the statistical
literature from the statistical
viewpoint
and that is that the regularizer is
encoding some prior
information we have about theta
specifically that the
regularized r of theta is actually small
and so this is a way of saying well we
believe
that the theta that generalizes now
that corresponds to the true predictor
underlying
the data the true model of the data
has a small theta and so we're going to
enforce that in our learning algorithm
we only look at thetas that are actually
small
and that's a completely uh a different
way of looking at
uh the purpose of the regularizer but
it's equally valid
uh in both cases you want
both the empirical risk l of theta
and the regularizer r of theta to be
small
so regularized empirical risk
minimization we
choose theta to minimize the empirical
risk
l er theta plus some positive constant
lambda
multiplied by r of theta the regularizer
and remember lambda here is called the
regularization hyperparameter
which we can trade off l of theta
against r of theta
and we choose it by validating against
data in a separate set called a test set
and the the trick of all of this of
course is that this actually works
it works in the sense that by enforcing
regularization we end up with
worse performance on the training set
but better performance on on the test
set and it's test set performance that
we actually care about
now when you're constructing
regularizers we've seen so far
the two norm used as a regularizer in
ridge regression
and a very common format for
regularizers is to have a penalty
function
q which is a function which maps the
real numbers to the real numbers
and the regularization of theta is
simply q of theta 1
plus q of theta 2 all the way up to all
of our parameters
theta p and so we penalize each of the
parameters each of the components
of theta separately and add up the
corresponding
penalizations and normally we choose
these
penalty functions q such that they're
non-negative
and so that they're only zero when
theta i is zero
and q of theta i is therefore expressing
our displeasure
in choosing the predictor coefficient
theta i and in particular
by defining it so that it increases with
the value of theta i
it expresses the fact that we prefer
small
theta eyes of a large speed of eyes
and so we've seen the case where
we have q of theta i is just theta i
squared
that's the sum of square regularizer
or ridge regression it's also called the
quadratic regularizer
the ticking off regularizer or the l2
regularizer
it's the q square function
it's just q square of a is a squared and
with that
penalty function then the regularizer is
just the norm
of theta squared and in particular
it's the two norm of theta squared
another very common regularizer is the
sum absolute
function where the penalty function that
we're using is q
abs the absolute value
function and that way the regularizer
function r of theta
is the sum of the absolute values of the
components of theta
that's called the one norm of the vector
theta um people would call that sum
absolute regularization or l1
regularization or
lasso regularization
another one we might see is the
non-negative regularizer
where the penalty function is
zero when a is greater than equal to
zero
and it's infinity when a is less than
and that's a very hard penalty
it says that the only theaters that we
will accept
are cedars for which all of the
components
of cedar are greater than equal to zero
so in other words we're enforcing the
fact that the predictor coefficients
have to be non-negative
and any minimizer which minimizes l of
theta plus
r of theta where r has this form
the only way you can have a minimizer is
if the resulting
theta is no negative
now let's uh look at this in the context
of sensitivity
and suppose we've got
a linear predictor g theta of x which is
theta transpose x
and this here is uh
we're predicting a scalar y
and we'll suppose that the feature
vector x changes
to x delta which is x plus some delta
and delta here is the perturbation or
change in x
and we'll assume for now that any delta
uh is possible but we're going to look
at the set
of perturbations
capital delta and we're only going to
allow
perturbations little delta that live in
this capital delta set
we'll call it the feature perturbation
set
and um we can say well suppose
theta is a predictor parameter
and x now changes to x plus delta
what happens to our prediction in that
case
the prediction becomes theta transpose
multiplied by
x plus delta and so
the change in the prediction is going to
be
theta transpose x tilde minus theta
transpose x
which is just going to be theta
transpose delta
so if we look at the absolute value of
that quantity
the absolute value of theta transpose
delta that's the magnitude of the change
in prediction
and we can ask ourselves well how big
can this be
when we're allowing delta to range in
some set capital delta
and we can look at the worst case
sensitivity the maximum
over all deltas in capital delta
of the absolute value of theta transpose
delta
this is a measure of sensitivity if
for some specific set capital delta
then we can say well this quantity tells
us
how much the prediction can change
in the worst case
so let's look at the case where we're
looking at l2
perturbations in other words we're
looking at the script
the set capital delta to be the set of
all
perturbations little delta with two norm
less than or equal to epsilon epsilon is
some number
and this is a ball this is a
sphere in delta space
so the set of deltas which are in
capital delta is a sphere capital delta
is a sphere
and this is called an l2 ball
and this means that the feature vector x
can change to any x tilde
within distance epsilon and in
particular we're measuring distance with
the tunnel
now as we've seen before the koshibart's
inequality tells us that the absolute
value of theta transpose delta
is less than or equal to the two norm of
theta multiplied by the two norm of
delta
and the two norm of delta we know has to
be less than or equal to epsilon
for all deltas in our allowed set and
that means that the
absolute value of theta transpose delta
is less than equal to epsilon times the
two norm of theta
so in particular the worst case
sensitivity is therefore
epsilon times the two norm of theta
and maximizing the change in the
prediction
out of all possible deltas that we're
allowed to choose
the one that maximizes the change in the
prediction
is um epsilon divided by the two norm of
theta
times theta in other words we take theta
and we normalize that vector and
multiply it by epsilon
and so this is a justification for the
sum of square
regularization if we are
concerned about
minimizing the worst case
sensitivity to
[Music]
changes in x which
are in a unit l2 ball
then the sum of square regularizer
measures exactly that it measures how
badly how much can the prediction
change when we know
that x can only change by
an amount epsilon
in distance
now that's a way of interpreting the
purpose of l2 regularization
it's uh it says what you're doing is
you're
minimizing the worst case response to
particular class of perturbations
now if we look at the
l infinity perturbation class
instead well then we'll get a different
appropriate choice of regularizer
so the infinity class of perturbations
that's the
allowed set of deltas the allowed sort
of changes to x
which for which each of the components
delta i has absolute value less than or
equal to epsilon
so people call that an l infinity ball
but of course really it's just
a cube people might call it a hypercube
in d
dimensions so capital delta here
is a cube and we're saying that you can
take an
x and perturb it by a vector which is in
this cube
and the the widths of the sides of this
cube are two epsilon
now and the reason it's called an l
infinity ball is that it
has exactly the same form as the
usual ball it's the norm of delta is
less than
or equal to epsilon it's the defining
characteristic of this ball
but here the norm is a different norm
instead of being the two norm
it's the infinity norm and the infinity
norm of a vector
delta is the maximum
of the absolute value of the components
of delta
this is a very complicated way of
defining a cube
in terms of a norm
so this means any component of the
feature vector can change by up to
epsilon
so instead of saying we're going to
think about changes to x
as being changes to the vector x
and they all live in sphere and if
you're going to have changes in the
sphere it means if you change a lot in
one direction then you can't change very
much in any other direction
here we're saying you can change all of
the components separately
and you can change all of those
components by up to epsilon
and with that kind of model how big can
the absolute value of theta transpose
delta b
um now there's a way of maximizing
the change in the absolute value of
theta transpose delta
when delta is required to be in a cube
and the idea is is that you take the
thetas
and you choose your deltas to be
epsilon times the sine of the thetas
so if theta i is positive
then you'll choose delta i to be epsilon
and if theta i is negative then you'll
choose delta i
to be minus epsilon and if you do that
then what you get is that the
change in the prediction theta transpose
times delta well that's becomes
theta transpose times sine of theta
where sine of theta is applied element
wise to the vector theta
or multiplied by epsilon
and that becomes epsilon times the sum
of the absolute values of theta which is
epsilon times the one norm of theta
in other words if
x is allowed to change by any
change any component by epsilon
possibly all of the components by up to
epsilon
the worst case change you're going to
have in theta transpose
x is epsilon times the sum of the
absolute values
of the theta i's and if you're concerned
about those kinds of perturbations
happening to x
then your regularizer that you should
choose is
the sum of the absolute regularizer so r
of theta should be
the one norm of theta which is the sum
of the absolute values
of c to i
now this is all well and good this is a
an
analysis of
what it means to
penalize this particular these
particular regularizers
um
it's important not to take this too
far or too seriously
this is a certainly gives us a way of
interpreting the meaning
of choosing these particular
regularizations
but it doesn't give us a way of choosing
which one we should apply in a
particular machine learning problem
the way we would do that
is well there's two ways one is that we
gain some experience with a wide range
of machine learning problems
and we see that for some types of
machine learning problems
the two norm regularizer tends to do
better and for other types of machine
learning problems
the one norm regularizer tends to do
better
and we'll have something to say along
those lines in this section
the other way is even more pragmatic
and that is to say validate
you want to know which one's better try
both of them
compute the performance compute the
empirical risk on your test set
and see which one did better
so we have now
uh two types of regularization
that we're going to focus on one is
two norm regularization and
if we're using the square loss remember
which is l
of y hat y is the square of y hat minus
y
again when y is scalar then if you
choose theta to minimize l of theta
plus lambda times the two norm of theta
squared that's called
ridge regression the other one we'll
focus on
is where we're using the one norm of
theta
as our regressor and then we're going to
be minimizing empirical risk
plus lambda times the one norm of theta
and that's called lasso regression
uh this was invented at stanford by
robert shirani in
1994 and lasso regularization
lasso regression is actually widely used
in advanced machine learning
um we saw for ridge regression
that even though it looks like an
extension
of least squares the problem actually
reduces to a least squares problem when
we can apply
the least squares formula to solve
explicitly
for the optimal theta
lasso regression doesn't have a formula
there is no analytical expression there
is no algebraic
expression for the
theta that minimizes the regularized
empirical risk
when the regularizer is the one norm
when the predictor
is linear then
if we're using square loss both ridge
regression
and lasso regression can be officially
computed
for ridge regression there's a formula
for lasso regression we have to use
numerical optimization
but these numerical optimization methods
are extremely
efficient and always converge
to the global optimal solution
because the problem is convex
now when we have a constant feature so
we have x one is one
the predictor coefficient theta one is
the offset
again when the predictor is linear so
in that case we have g
theta of x is
theta one plus theta two x
two
and so
x1 doesn't change even
when
our x changes
we do not consider perturbations to x1
because x1 is the constant feature so
delta 1 is always considered to be 0.
as a result theta 1 does not contribute
to predictor
sensitivity and
as a result we do not regularize the
associated coefficients to one
and so we modify both regularizers to
only include
terms from c to two through d c to d we
either take the two norm
of c to the two through c to d or
the one law of theta two so c d
now there's a specific property
of certain regular devices which is very
useful
and that's to do with sparseness so
if i have a linear predictor g theta of
x is theta transpose x
well if theta is sparse sparse here
means that many of the entries of theta
are zero so the number of non-zero
components of theta is small compared to
the length of theta
then as a result the prediction theta
transpose x
doesn't depend on some of the features x
in particular it doesn't depend on those
features
x i for which theta i is zero
um it means that well if i've got a
predictor that only uses some features
rather than thinking about it as g theta
of all of x i can think about it as g
theta of just those particular
components of x
those with which c to i is non-zero
and this side can have practical
benefits
um uh in particular
um you can make the predictor simpler to
interpret instead of having a
prediction as to somebody's illness
based on
a thousand different measured properties
and diagnostic tests we might have a
prediction which is actually only
depends on a few
and that can be much more useful it's
also much cheaper if i want to
decide that i'm going to try and
diagnose somebody's health using such an
algorithm
if i only have to run four or five blood
tests
rather than 50 or 60 that's a huge
savings
um so the predictor is simpler to
interpret it's
cheaper to actually execute um and you
can actually get better performance
now this happens when some of the
components xi some of the regressors
are actually irrelevant so
imagine we're in a situation where we've
got y
and we've got x and some of the
components of x
actually don't affect y at all you know
we might be trying to
fit house price and we've got various
components of x
such as a lot area lot size number of
bedrooms
but we've also got components of x such
as
the current weather in barcelona which
may be totally irrelevant to the house
price in mountain view
even if it's irrelevant our learning
algorithm
may assign that
regressor that component a non-zero
seater
because it achieves slightly better
performance on the training set with a
non-zero seater
then it does with the zeros here
and that's totally reasonable and that's
exactly what will typically happen
the learning algorithm can't tell
the difference between components
of the
variables x which are just noise and
components which are actually meaningful
if choosing non-zero components makes
the empirical risk smaller
that's what it'll do um
but of course it's total nonsense from a
practical perspective
we've got a predictor that
we know is fitting the wrong thing
um and so if we could somehow remove
those irrelevant
aggressors then we might
if not achieve better training loss
which we won't do
but we might achieve better test laws
and so by if we can somehow induce
sparsity
in our linear predictor
if we can induce sparsity in a linear
predictor then
it may enable us to remove
those components of theta which don't
really matter but just happen to be
correlated the right way
with the training data
this idea that we're going to choose the
sparsity pattern of theta
is called feature selection
and there are several different ways of
carrying it out
one in particular is core is to use l1
regularization
and it is a an important property
of l1 regularization that it leads to
sparse
coefficient vectors
in other words if we use r of theta as
the one norm
of theta and we minimize
empirical risk plus lambda times the one
norm of theta
as a consequence of that structure the
structure of that optimization problem
we will tend to
produce thetas that are sparse
so one explanation for this when
we're using a square penalty well once
you've made theta small
theta squared is really very small
and so the incentive for the sum of
squares regularizer to make a
coefficient smaller
decreases once theta already becomes
small
for the absolute penalty that doesn't
happen once
um theta becomes small well
theta squared may become very small but
the absolute value of theta doesn't
necessarily become very small it just
has the same scale as theta
and so the incentive to make theta small
continues until
theta is actually zero of course that's
a very rough
explanation uh one can do a more
sophisticated mathematical analysis to
show
that in fact the
one norm of theta produces sparse
feeders when one uses the one norm as a
regularization
we're not going to do that in this class
but we will
see it in practice
so here's an example on the left hand
side we have ridge regression
and on the right hand side we have lasso
regression
and so the left hand two plots are the
usual
regularization path plots that we make
here we have the
test loss which increases
as a function of lambda and we have the
training loss
in this case we see that the training
loss also increases with lambda
we might sometimes get a small dip in
the
test loss we also see
in the bottom plot the usual shrinkage
we see
the magnitude of theta
in the size of the various components of
theta at a particular value of lambda
and we see that those numbers get
smaller
as we increase theta as we increase
lambda now in the right hand side
we have the same plots but for
lasso when we're using l1 regularization
and here we can see very similar
training loss one noticeable feature
is that there's a sharp corner there and
that's a characteristic feature
of lasso regression
we also see that the
test loss has a much more
marked dip
with a significantly smaller test loss
than in the l2 regularized
case um
now why is this and the reason is
is that the lasso regression
is eliminating the irrelevant features
let's look at the regularization path
for theta
what you can see is
that as we increase lambda
the components of theta tend to
zero and they tend to zero
and hit zero exactly and then stay there
and they hit zero
exactly at a particular value of lambda
and each one of them will hit um
lambda one after the other and
eventually we'll end up with a
completely
zero exactly zero predictor which will
be
in this case for lambda
here which is a little bit larger
than one for lambda a little bit smaller
than one
we have a predictor
that consists of two non-zero components
of theta
and back here we have three and once
we're back to here we have
maybe 20 non-zero components
of theta and this sudden hitting
of zero exactly is what causes
the sharp corner
in the last path as well
and so the lasso regression
is selecting features for us it's
selecting those features which
are relevant to the training problem
and it's removing those features which
are irrelevant and it's removing them
exactly now because they
are the features that are removed are
irrelevant
they're simply noise fitting them
to the training data may improve
training loss but it will have the
downside
that it will inherently make the test
loss
worse and that's why we see such a
distinction
between the lasso test loss
in the ridge teslas
here are the results so on the top we
have ridge regression
with the square regularizer
and on the bottom plot we have lasso
regularization with the absolute
regularizer the on the top we can see
that this is
so this is a plot of the components
of theta sorted
and so first of all we take the
components of theta we take the absolute
value
and then we plot the sorted absolute
values
and you can see that for the ticking off
regularization
that all 200 of the components of theta
are non-zero
and as we go down the list they decay
but rather slowly every one
of those x's is being used
in some way or another to predict why
for a lasso and this particular optimal
lambda
only the first 35
components of theta are non-zero
the other 165 components are exactly
zero and so we have a predictor
which doesn't use in any way 165
components of x which are the irrelevant
components of x now after we've trained
with
lasso we can pick a particular lambda
where we've only got a few
components left which are non-zero so
we've done feature selection to select
the features that are most important so
here
we've looked at the lambda where we've
reduced
the predictor to only using seven
features
and if we look back at our plot that is
somewhere here
there's some cut off lambda value at
which there's only seven
non-zero components of theta left
and then what we can do is we can
retrain we can take all of our x's
cut off all of the components
of x for which the corresponding theta
that we have
has a zero entry and as a result our
x's will reduce from being 200
dimensional to being only
seven dimensional in this case and then
with a seven dimensional x
we can retrain using either ticking off
regression
or lasso regression and what do we see
we see on the left here we see ridge or
ticking off
on the right here we see lasso
we see on the left for the plots of
theta that we're seeing
the usual shrinkage as we increase
lambda and on the right we're seeing
lasso star shrinkage where the
components
are going down to touch zero
exactly however the key thing about
these two plots is if we look at the
test loss
in both plots we're getting test loss
which is similar
and that's because feature selection has
happened
and what we have now is
only those features
those components of x which are relevant
to the problem we're trying to solve
which are relevant to y
and as a result blesso has no components
to remove which won't affect
the test loss
yeah in a significant way and
conversely ridge regression has no extra
components
to use which you can which it would
normally use to overfit
now the specification property of
um the one
norm can be strengthened
so remember what these regularizers look
like
if we plot them then
so this will be a component of theta and
this
will be the absolute value
um or we can look at the component of
theta
and look at the square
now if we want to make this a sharper
corner here
then we would have a stronger specifier
one way we might make it a sharper
corner
is to replace the penalty function with
a penalty function that does this
now as a result we've got an even
greater incentive
on regularized empirical risk
minimization
to make the components of theta exactly
zero
some people would call this the l one
half regularizer
that is a little bit of a misnomer
because the
the the nomenclature lp
refers to the p norm and so
um if i use p as a half then that that
says i'm using
the one half norm and it turns out that
that quantity which should be defined as
the sum over i of theta i
absolute value to the one half
or squared is not actually a norm it
doesn't satisfy the triangle inequality
and so um we tend to avoid
calling this the l one half regularizer
uh this is a stronger specifier it uh
it's not convex however
and as a result uh algorithms to compute
this
may not work as well as
the one norm or two norm regularizers
here's an example on the left
we have the plots
for ridge regression in the middle
we have plots for lasso
or l1 regression and on the right we
have an example computed with
the square root regularizer and we can
see
that we've getting some very similar
behavior for the square root regularizer
as we do for the
absolute value regularizer where we're
getting exact
sparsification and some as we increase
lambda
some of the components of
theta go to zero exactly
now let's have one more look at one more
regularizer this is the non-negative
regularizer
so sometimes we know or require that
theta i
should be greater than or equal to zero
so when x i increases so
must our prediction um
and that means that we'd like to impose
the constraint that theta is greater
than or equal to zero
on the empirical risk minimization
one way to do this is to have a
regularizer
which charges a cost
to the in the objective function which
is infinite when theta i
is negative and is zero when theta
i is non-negative um so you might have
this for example
if your target variable is life span and
x measures healthy behavior
um
people would call this non-negative
least squares
if you're doing quadratic loss
so one one way of solving these kinds of
problems
is to solve the least squares problem
for a theater and then say okay well
i've got at least
a theta which minimizes the square
loss so it's empirical risk minimization
and i'm going to take that theta and any
components of it which
are negative i'm going to set to zero
people we might write that as theta
l s plus
um it turns out that doesn't work very
well
because the minimization has been done
without
any knowledge of the constraint that the
components of theta have to be
non-negative
and the negative components that we've
set to zero might actually be very
important
it's much better to actually impose it
as a regularization
term on the object on the minimization
problem
and solve the minimization knowing that
we would like theta
to have non-negative components
here's a specific example here we have
a one-dimensional u
and a one dimensional v we've set y
equal to v
and we've constructed features from u
the features
are one the constant feature u
and then u minus 0.2 plus
remember what that is u plus u minus 0.2
plus
um if i plot that
this will be u and this is going to be u
minus a plus
this is the point a and this is the
function
and so it in it the resulting
predictor is going to be piecewise
linear
and uh it's going to have
kinks in it at these points
0.2 we've got 0.4 0.6
0.8 in this list here
and so we're going to have a piecewise
linear
predictor now if we want
see if we're going to impose the
constraint the theta i
be non-negative
well what does the predictor look like
the predictor
looks like y hat
is theta 1 plus theta
2 u plus theta 3
u minus 0.2 plus
plus theta 4 u minus 0.4
plus and so on
so if the thetas are non-negative well
it means that theta 1
is non-negative so at 0 the function
y hat has to be positive it means that
theta
2 is non-negative which means that
when u is less than 0.2
the function is just theta 1 plus theta
2 u
and so that has to have a
non-negative slope
so if we look at this predictor between
the values of u is point two and the val
and u is point four then we find that
the slope in that region
is theta two plus
theta three because both c two two and c
three are non-negative that slope is
greater than or equal to the slope
at between 0 and 0.2
which is just theta 2.
so all of the theta's being non-negative
means that the function must be
non-decreasing and it must be convex
as we increase u the slope has to
increase
so here's a data set and here's the
predictor
here's the predictor it's this is the
optimal
non negative least
squares fit where we've used a
non-negative regularizer
and
we can see that the function indeed is
convex
and non-decreasing this is the optimal
least squares fit
certainly piecewise linear has to be
it's convex but it's not non-decreasing
now if we use our heuristic and we say
well what we're going to do
is we're going to take that theta
and simply adjust it so that all of the
components of theta are on are
non-negative
in particular here we see that theta
two is less than zero and so we change
this function to make by making theta
two equal to zero
then we end up with a function that
looks like this
and that's uh that's
an extremely poor fit to the data
we can see here that the non-negative
least squares loss is 0.59
the least squares loss of course does
better because
it doesn't have the constraint that the
coefficients be non-negative and so it
does better with 0.3
but the heuristic loss is 15 because the
data
this uh approach this heuristic
is not guaranteed to work so the message
here is that
simply taking the least squares
predictor and truncating it
can perform very badly indeed much
better
to use a non-negative regularizer
let's summarize you want to choose a
regularizer
ultimately the thing you have to do is
use validation
if you've got a choice between two
different regularizers that you have in
mind say
l1 and l2 try them both and see one
see which one gives you the best test
loss
and the way we do that well we know is
that
we choose a range of lambdas we do r
e r m regularized empirical risk
minimization of each one
to compute a predictor and then we take
those predictors we evaluate them on the
test set
and then we choose the lambda that gives
the best test error
that tells you the very the variation of
the test performance as a function of
lambda
now we're going to do that with each of
our different regularizers and we'll use
the regularization that gives the best
test error
beyond that we've talked a little bit
about some
situations in which one might expect
lasso to perform better than
ridge regression and in particular the
situation that's
most common is when there are irrelevant
features in your data
we've seen also that the importance of
getting rid of those features can be
very significant
if it costs you a lot to collect data
then
getting rid of some unwanted data can be
a really useful thing to do
to save you having to collect the data
for future tests
um ultimately though it's important not
to
believe that one can a priori
determine which regularizer to use you
have to
determine it based on validation